hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of this year's Champions chess tour it
is Wesley so versus Magnus Carlson and
this is the third game of the match
first two games ended in a draw and this
one may or may not have end in a draw so
let's check it out and the Wesley first
game that they played he actually opened
with Pawn to B3 and it was a very nice
game but like I said it ended in a draw
uh this game he tries something else he
goes for Pawn to E4 so let's see what
Magnus has in mind as usual he replies
with Pawn to C5 he goes for the Ilan
defense but already a surprise on move
two he doesn't go for any standard stuff
like D6 E6 or Knight to F6 or something
he goes A6 this is the O Kelly variation
and it can bring some very interesting
positions if uh let's say if you
continue with something like D4 which is
a pretty standard way of treating the
Sicilian here it's a little bit
different because after C captures a
knight captures let's say Knight to F6
okay your E4 Pawn is hanging you play
Knight to C3 and already black can play
Pawn to E5 and it's it's much different
than playing E5 without having the pawn
on E6 on A6 because now the B5 square
has been taken away from the Knight and
once the Knight Retreats for example you
bring the bishop to this beautiful
diagonal and once white figures out how
to how to set up the pieces you have to
develop the bishop you have the castle
you can play D6 and already you have
your pawns and dark squares with your
Bishop outside of the cage and the light
Square Bishop has some very natural
developing squares so you're very happy
so that's why here you don't go for
something like U open the centry
immediately you play something else
usually C4 is played or C3 or even Pawn
to G3 but Wesley plays Bishop to E2 it's
an extremely rare move never been played
in top level chess and it's basically a
waiting move to see what Magnus will do
and how he will set up his structure and
okay Magnus goes for D6 and now it's a
little bit easier to figure out where to
put what so he strikes with Pawn to D4
now uh it's a little bit different C
capturas and he doesn't go for Knight
captus he actually goes for Queen
capturas and it's already now as of move
five that we have a completely new game
so okay Knight to C6 you want to attack
the queen uh Queen to D3 and now Pawn to
G6 getting ready to F to the dark Square
Bishop we have castles and Bishop to G7
we have uh sorry Bishop to G7 Knight to
C3 and now Knight to F6 uh this is the
aonan system of the oi variation we have
Knight to D5 always an excellent Square
for the Knight against any Sicilian
setup uh castles and now Pawn to C3
diminishing the power of the bishop on
G7 and also controlling the Knight on C6
also preparing in sunlines Knight to D4
and so on so here we have Pawn to B5
preparing to bring the bishop over to B7
uh Bishop to G5 and now Magnus trades on
D5 we have Knight captures Pawn captures
and Knight to E5 offering further trades
we have Knight captures on E5 Bishop
captures and now we have Pawn to H4
preparing Pawn to H5 to go after
magnus's King uh Bishop to F5 attacking
the queen here and queen back to D2 and
now Pawn to H5 stopping any H5 ideas
from Wesley uh Bishop to D3 countering
the light Square Bishop on F5 and here
Queen to D7 and defending the bishop we
have Rook a to E1 and just Rook F to E8
we have Rook to E3 doubling uh preparing
to double up on the E file uh and Rook a
to C8 Magnus has some ideas of maybe
doubling up on the C file and then later
on A5 B4 to break open the structure
here so Rook F to E1 doubling up and
Bishop captures on D3 Queen captures and
Rook to C4 uh so gaining uh control over
the over the fort rank uh we have Pawn
to G3 adding another Defender to the H4
pawn and now Rook e to C8 doubling up on
the C file we have Rook to E4 and now
King to G7 H we have King to G2 and now
Pawn to A5 preparing to strike here with
Pawn to B4 and uh we have A3 Wesley
stops that and now Rook eight um at C5
putting pressure on the D5 Pawn but also
just winning a bit more space and here
Magnus said after the game that he felt
that uh the only way you can defeat
Wesley is to hustle him because if
you've seen interviews of the players um
describing Wesley's play everyone just
says that he's so extremely solid uh
that you just can't touch him so the
only way to actually beat Wesley is to
somehow somehow trick him uh into
defeating himself and here if you if you
just let's say Play Bishop back to E3
you go after the Rook okay some happen
captures captures Rook to C4 you attack
the queen and after Queen D3 let's say
you offer a queen trade okay a queen
trade happens uh yeah it's a nice game
perhaps black will have a little bit
more Advantage as he controls more space
but all in all it's perfectly fine and
playable for white however after Pawn to
F4 this is where Magnus says that he was
sort of able to hustle Wesley but not
hustle him into to blundering the game
but sort of hustl him into giving him a
better position now the problem is as
magnus's only weakness realistically is
the east S Pawn it's a backwards Pawn
it's a terrible Pawn attacked by pretty
much everything here the two Rooks and
the bishop by playing Pawn to F4 Wesley
pretty much solves all of magnus's
problems so Magnus plays Rook captures
on e4 uh it doesn't matter if you
capture back with the queen or The Rook
Rook captures on e4 was played and now
he just plays Bishop to F6 and this
solves his problem of the weak E7 Pawn
uh Wesley captures on F6 but also it
doesn't matter if you don't then the
bishop just remains here as a nice
Defender so he captures here e captures
on F6 okay it's a doubled Pawn but at
least you've eliminated the weakness
from E7 and now Rook to
D4 uh we have Rook back to C8 now Magnus
wants to gain control over the open E
file and Wesley moves The Rook back Rook
to E4 now Rook to B8 signaling that
Magnus is now ready to play Pawn to B4
and as you no longer have to worry about
the E7 weakness now you are free to
explore your options on the queen side
so King to H2 and now Queen to F5
preparing to trade Queens if the Rook
moves moves and that's exactly what
Wesley does he offers a queen trade as
objectively the end game is a draw Queen
captures Rook captures and now Rook to
uh E8 but uh if you look at the clock
times Magnus is even worse on the clock
than Wesley he has a minute and 13
seconds whereas Wesley has a minute and
35 seconds so okay Rook to D2 of course
you want to stop um the advancement of
The Rook all the way to the second rank
you do not want to allow it to become a
pig uh and now Magnus strikes on the
king side with Pawn to G5 of course he
would like to UND double his pawns here
King to G2 and now he plays G captures
on H4 we have G captures on H4 and now
Rook to E3 so if you look at the pawn
structure Wesley has three Pawn Islands
whereas Magnus has four Pawn Islands so
you know everything you know about end
Games should tell you that the Wesley is
a little bit better here but magnus's
Rook is a bit more active so you know
it's um you know uh sort of equal is uh
and here we have Pawn to F5 now you
could also go for King to F2 and allow
Rook to H3 also the reason why Magnus
play Rook to E3 is sort of to prevent
Wesley's King from uh activating but
here even King to F2 is possible because
if Rook H4 you can even give up the pawn
here now King G2 King captures and now
you go Rook D4 and The Rook is kind of
trapped on H4 these three squares are
covered by the king okay you can give
one check but doesn't matter The Rook
will not be able to escape and then you
are free to play A4 and go after the
pawns or if captures then Rook captures
Rook captures on A5 and so on so uh one
way to do it but uh Wesley said all
right let's go Pawn to F5 first his idea
is that okay now if he attacks the rook
and Magnus goes after the pawn he can
defend it with Rook to D4 and still go
for the same idea uh so it's basically
the longer way of doing the same thing
but this allows Magnus to improve his
position slightly so King f8 but now
they're very much low on the clock 39
seconds versus 42 seconds King F2 we
have Rook to E5 going after the F5 Pawn
now and pawn to B4
uh there's a trade on B4 captures
captures and now Magnus eliminates the
F5 Pawn with check King to E3 and now
Rook to E5 with check we have King to F4
Westley gains a lot of activity with his
King for the price of that one Pawn King
to E7 and now Rook to
D4 uh we have King to D7 and now Rook
back to D1 we have Rook to E2 trying to
go behind the the backwards C pawn and
now Rook to A1 trying to harass magnus's
King as the pawn on D5 really does a
nice job of boxing him in so Rook to D2
first going after the D5 Pawn now Rook
to A7 check King to E8 and now King to
F5 going after the F6 Pawn Rook to F2
check of course you do not want to allow
this capture then the king Rook combo
will be more than you can handle King to
E4 and now Pawn to F5 check even we have
King to E3 and only now Rook to C2 so
you can see how this is much better
going after the C2 Pawn with the white
king here than with the white king here
and now Wesley played King to F4 notice
that if you play King to D3 yeah you can
still play it like Rook C1 King to D2
Rook to H1 um but now Rook B7 and
there's going to be a trade here and
then it's a race the past H Pawn versus
the past B Pawn objectively it's a draw
but you know just uh thought I'd share
that you could also play that so King to
F4 was played and now we have Rook
captures and C3 King captures on F5 and
now Rook to C4 it's just easier for
Magnus to hone in on Wesley weaknesses
and also he's just up a pawn we have
King to G5 and now Rook captures on B4
uh Rook to B7 putting the rook in front
of the pass pawn and now Rook to B5 B1
or in this case behind the pass Pawn
King captures on H5 and now Pawn to B4
Magnus starts advancing his pass pawn
and now King to H6 and it seems like uh
you should move your king away from the
pass Pawn so the pass Pawn can advance
but if you put the king here uh then the
king becomes a target for the the black
Rook just to give you a quick example
let's say B3 H5 B2 H6 and now Rook to G1
check is a problem because B1 brings a
queen into the game let's say King F6
you're going to bring a Queen into the
game uh and after white captures sure
you will play H7 Rook to H1 you're even
going to win the pawn uh but H now comes
Pawn to F5 and the F Pawn wins the game
doesn't matter if you trade here
captures captures the pawn is just
Unstoppable so that's why Wesley plays
King H6 which is the correct move and
still this position is objectively a
draw
uh But Here Comes Pawn to F5 and the
pawn to F5 maybe a slight imprecision
because here Magnus allowed King to G5
King to G5 is still a draw for Wesley uh
because not because you go after the
pawn but because you can actually hide
your king behind the pawn and get away
from from the checks point being that if
King G5 let's say Pawn to B3 you're
going to play Pawn to H5 and now after
Pawn to B2 you do not have a check
because of King F6 and now the The Rook
cannot move as The Rook would pick up
the B2 Pawn so here let's say Pawn F4
Pawn H6 Pawn to F3 H7 and now let's say
Rook to H1 now you get Rook captures on
B2 and now the problem is how do you
continue here if you play Rook captures
on H7 then you even lose the game Rook
B8 check Follow by King D7 Rook B7 check
picks up the Rook on H7 so what you
would have to do here is play F2 first
threaten the queen with check and only
after The Rook moves from the B file now
you capture on H7 and now it's a draw
King E6 you're going to check defend
your pawn and that's pretty much it uh
but after F5 Wesley got tricked by this
Pawn to F5 move or as Magnus says he got
hustled and he went for Pawn to H5 but
now the position is completely winning
for Magnus Now Pawn to F4 King to G5 and
now even Pawn to F3 we have Pawn to H6
Pawn to F2 and now Rook to B8 with check
we have King D7 Rook B7 check King to C8
now no more no more checks and now Pawn
to H7 Wesley hopes that Magnus uh takes
the Rook so he can play play h8 Queen uh
but Magnus just played Rook to G1 and he
was in this position on move 60 that
Wesley so resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here now the
problem is if you move the king let's
say okay you go to H6 now just F1 Queen
and yes Wesley would also Queen with
check but the problem is King captures
on B7 now the being up a rook means
really a lot as there are no more checks
here uh you can give a queen queen H7
check but then after the king hides you
will just get checkmated on the next
move there
not nothing you can do here uh and other
moves after Rook to G1 the the engine
sort of um uh recorded King F6 is
Wesley's last move but I don't think he
played that I mean he probably just
picked it up didn't know what to do he
ran out of time and then he just dropped
it on F6 but again it's pointless
because F1 check and then you just um
well do pretty much anything doesn't
really matter like King t7 you can go
Queen E1 check once the king moves Queen
F2 check and if King goes here now you
even play King captur some B7 h8 Queen
and now Rook to E1 with check that's all
there is King to D7 Queen to F7 with
check and now whatever King captures
here and queen to C7 for example will be
Checkmate but any other variation also
ends in Checkmate uh so yeah very nicely
played by both of them uh but Magnus was
better in this one he was able to hustle
Wesley and as as I've understood it from
the interview after the game it is
pretty much the only way you can beat
Wesley as he's just so incredibly solid
uh so this was game three and Wesley had
a chance to equalize the match in game
four if he wins with the black pieces
but it was a it was a draw it was a
pretty equal game throughout the entire
run uh so you know Wesley will have to
look for his chances in the second game
of the finals where he will have to win
the first match in order to tie the
match and then take the match into tie
breaks which means there will be another
match so uh tomorrow we we might even
have two Armageddon so we'll see what
happens but yeah very nicely done and uh
yeah if if you need to uh to surprise
your opponent if you know your opponent
is really awesome against the Sicilian
Defense maybe try this o Kelli variation
and maybe you also will have some uh
some some Success With It uh so that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to thank Robert arathun Sam's
giant tortois farm the Night Before
Christmas good luck on law school finals
KV and Benjamin hyberger for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and whatever
else happened in the Chess World uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day